Let's make homemade yogurt together.
So I like to use raw milk,
but you can also use pasteurized.
I'm heating a half a gallon of milk up to 188 degrees.
Then I pour it off and let it cool to 115.
Then I'm gonna whisk in two
tablespoons of yogurt I saved from the last batch,
getting it all incorporated,
and then I just cover it with Saran wrap,
and I put it in my warmer,
which is just a cabinet with a thermostat and heat lamp.
This is at 115 degrees all night long,
12 to 24 hours, until the next morning when it's done.
My yogurt turns out really wet.
There's a lot of extra way
so you can drain that off by straining it with cheesecloth,
but I just leave it wet,
and I stir in oats for my husband's breakfast muesli.
Thanks for joining me. Enjoy.